اذا اتواجد الان في احد المراكز التجاريه
الكبيره في قلب المدينه خيرسون الذي تعرض
فجر هذا اليوم لقصف مكثف من قبل القوات
الروسيه وفقا للاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه
هنا في
المقاطعه كما تشاهدون الدمار في كل مكان
فرق الدفاع المدني في هذه الاثناء ما زالت
تواصل اطفاء الحريق منذ ساعات طويله القصف
وقع فجر هذا اليوم متجر كان مغلقا لذلك لم
يكن هنالك ضحايا في صفوف المدنيين او
العاملين في المركز لكن واضح بان الخساره
كانت كبيره ومحققه وفقا للقائمين على هذا
المتجر الخاص في قلب المدينه الجنوبيه
الذي تتعرض او التي تتعرض لقصف متواصل منذ
ايام من قبل القوات الروسيه خلال الساعات
الماضيه تتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه وف
ارتفاع المدني عن اكثر من اربعين هجوما
بالمدفعيه
والصواريخ وبقدائف الهاون من القوات
الروسيه المتواجده على الضفه الشرقيه في
خيرسون والحديث ايضا عن خسائر في الارواح
لاسيما عند القرى الواقعه على طول خطوط
التماس بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
فيرسون تامر الجزيره